let's move on to the biggest shake-up
and America's Got Talent
history I want you to take a good look
at this team because you will never see
them together again it's like a rule of
cool survive this show Mel be out this
is real what's happening yet Heidi Klum
out Tyra Banks outside but the men on
the show how Ian Simon they are saying
it is the biggest shake-up in years et
is confirmed when the series returns for
season 14 Gabrielle Union and Julianne
Hough will be judges Terry Crews who
currently hosts AGT the champions will
replace Tyra Tyra doesn't come back for
a GT during the summer are you down
listen our et source maintains there was
no behind-the-scenes drama or bad blood
leading up to the talent overhaul Tyra
Heidi and Mel B were all informed of the
changes
yesterday morning quote it was a network
decision the show does well because it
has no problem adding new people and
making changes to dream the impossible
dream I'm not surprised that this show
is so successful I only concentrate on
myself on what I bring to the table
since 2006 there have been eleven judges
and five hosts who ever evolved through
the doors of a GT Terry recently told et
he didn't ask to pass hosts for advice
before signing on to the franchise I
actually specifically did not try to get
any pointers that way from from Nick or
tired of both good friends of mine but I
wanted to bring what I was gonna bring
you know what I mean it was like oh you
know I was like I'm gonna pop my pen you
can't tell me not to
[Applause]
[Music]